what's up wisecrack jared again if you
haven't noticed we really really love
Rick and Morty unfortunately we're still
desperately waiting for the rest of
season 3 and more of that sweet sweet
Szechuan sauce this sauce is amazing
but to tide you guys over we thought
we'd put philosophy aside and take a
look at another element that makes Rick
and Morty so great showrunners dan
harmon and justin roiland mastery of
story structure welcome to this
wisecrack edition on how Rick and Morty
tells a story but before we get into it
we just want to thank kwid for
sponsoring this video so what is quit
quit is a new app where you can collect
exclusive digital stickers cards and
toys for free featuring all the shows we
love here at wisecrack Breaking Bad
Adventure Time Bob's Burgers Star Trek
and most importantly Rick and Morty you
know I was a little skeptical at first
but getting to slap Rick Sanchez
stickers on my desperate pleas to get
Jacob to join me for Korean barbecue is
really fun it's my Szechuan sauce
seriously they've made a pretty fun game
of collecting them too you open up packs
of stickers and cards it kind of brings
me back to the days of opening up
basketball cards as a kid you can also
showcase your collection by adding
stickers to anything on your camera roll
and my dog woody always looks best when
he's chillin with snuffles and they've
got Funko pop figures too so I grabbed
myself this meeseeks to serve as a
friendly reminder that existence is pain
check out the description below for a
link to grab the app for free it's
available on iOS and Android but it's
not as smooth on Android yet since it's
still in beta anyway I'm on there as
jarred c-137 so add me as a friend and
trade me all your Mii seek swag now
let's get on with the show
Dan Harmon states that every story from
the Odyssey to your standard fart joke
follows eight simple steps Harmon called
it the story embryo and it goes like
this
number one a character is in a zone of
comfort number two but they want
something number three they enter an
unfamiliar situation number four adapt
to it number five get what they wanted
number six pay a heavy price for it
number seven then return to their
familiar
situation number 8 having changed of
course this can all change based on the
genre and medium and it especially
changes for television whereas a movies
goal is to send viewers out on a 90
minute high television is a bit
different it aims to keep people
watching television forever Harmon says
that this is all to put your brain in a
vegetative state so that the commercials
can do their work
this means television shows are less
about change and more about preserving
the status quo in the Dark Knight Rises
Batman saves Gotham before jetting off
to Italy to start a new life
while in Batman the Animated Series you
can bet your bottom dollar that each
episode begins and ends with Batman
fighting a different villain in the same
old Gotham in Harmons words television
swaps out any meaningful and therefore
potentially television subverting truth
with the basic eternal truth that change
is unnecessary with that in mind the
structure of a TV episode often ends up
looking more like this one I the
protagonist to notice a small problem 3
and make a major decision for this
changes things 5 to some satisfaction
but 6 there are consequences 7 that must
be undone 8 and I must admit the
futility of change so do Justin roiland
and Dan Harmon follow their own advice
absolutely every episode of Rick and
Morty follows this format but for the
sake of time let's see how it plays out
in one of my favorites season 2 episode
6 the Rick's must be crazy
step 1 establish a protagonist in a zone
of comfort Harmon says it's best not to
screw around here and fade immediately
onto characters doing something
relatable this episode does just that
opening with summer Rick and Morty
coming out of the movie ball fondlers'
in just 20 short seconds the episode has
told us who our protagonist are and what
they and their world is like there's
pros and cons to every alternate
timeline fun facts about this one it's
got giant telepathic spiders 11 9 11 and
the best ice cream in the multiverse and
25 seconds later the script moves to
step to introduce a small problem and
establish a need step two is where the
protagonist realizes that life isn't
perfect
in a teenage love story this is when a
hero wonders why he can't be the high
school quarterback and date the
cheerleader in a horror film this is
when the group of teens first hears that
someone was murdered in the woods 13
years ago for the Sanchez family though
it's when Rick's ship refuses to start
oh great huh looks like something's
wrong with the Microverse battery we're
gonna have to go inside in two lines
Rick sets up the central problem and
motivation of the script the ship's
battery is dead and they need to fix it
in typical hero fashion Morty is
reluctant to start this journey this
reluctance is an often-used narrative
trick that helps us identify with the
protagonist in this case Morty
Morty's uncertainty of the situation
becomes our uncertainty and we find
ourselves more invested in the story 10
seconds later and the script moves us to
step 3 the protagonist makes a major
decision and enters an unfamiliar
situation step 3 is where the descent
into the unknown begins in the case of
Rick and Morty the descent is both a
figurative and a literal one on one
level the two are leaving their comfort
zone and entering one characterized by
danger and uncertainty
while on a more literal level they're
actually shrinking down to visit a world
inside Rick's car battery posing as
aliens
there's nothing dishonest about what
we're doing now slap on these antennae
these people need to think we're aliens
Harmon says it's not that important how
big or epic your story is but rather how
noticeable the contrast is between your
two worlds this episode takes that
premise and runs with it
introducing us to a world that is
completely foreign to our own it's
populated by Martian like people living
in power plants inspire buildings who
venerate Rick for introducing them to
electricity unknown to them the
Stairmaster like Google boxes Rick gave
them actually redirect most of their
power to Rick's hip and like the dick of
a god he is Rick has guided their
civilization in some messed-up ways
Morty gotta flip them off I told them
that means peace among world
hilarious is that which brings us to
step four characters adapt to the new
situation and things must change step
four is all about the characters
learning their place in this new world
it's where all of their neuroses are
broken down and their psychological
baggage is slowly stripped away movie
producers call it the training phase but
remember TV isn't about selling change
it's about preserving the status quo so
you'll tune in week after week as such
this stage is much less about internal
change and much more about external
change once they arrive in the
Microverse Rick and Morty orient
themselves in this new world and
identify the problem at hand
zip Zam floor zeep is perhaps the most
familiar and strangest aspect of this
Microverse essentially a carbon copy of
Rick himself I dropped out of school
it's not a place for smart people ZP
even creates his own micro burst to
generate his planets electricity which
makes Rick's gooble boxes obsolete and
his car battery unusable faced with a
mirror image of themselves you'd expect
a normal character to own up to their
own hypocrisy and begin to change but
not Rick Rick shamelessly parrots the
same objections Morty had made to him
earlier a shot which is almost visually
identical in the earlier scene it just
sounds like slavery with extra steps
sounds like slavery with extra steps ich
Barba Dirk Oh somebody's gonna get laid
in college and when Morty later calls
Rick out on his hypocrisy Rick seizes
upon this as a chance to stop Z this is
the things must change part a new
conflict is introduced Rick must search
for a scientist in zips Microverse
working on his own micro burst somewhere
on this planet there's got to be an
arrogant scientist prick on the verge of
Microverse technology which would
threaten to make seeps flugel cranks
obsolete forcing zeep to say Mike
reverses are bad at which point he'll
realize what a hypocrite he's being his
people will go back to stomping on their
Google boxes this sets us up for step 5
the character gets what they wanted if
you look at the diagram you'll notice
Step five is at the very bottom of the
circle opposite of step one where the
hero is most comfortable here the hero
has hit rock bottom and has finally
found what they were looking for even if
it wasn't quite what they had expected
this
is the first major turning point to the
story where your characters motivations
begin to change if you want a plot twist
Harmon says to twist here and twist hard
Rick reaches step five when he gets what
he wants he finds a scientist named Kyle
in zips Microverse who created his own
micro verse in an inception like moment
we travel into a micro verse within a
micro verse within another Microverse
Rick sits back and watches in smug
satisfaction as Zeke repeats to Kyle the
exact same slavery rant we've heard
three times in the last eight minutes
did we mention that comedy comes in
threes that just sounds like slavery
with extra depth but as he continues his
rants he realizes that his own universe
is a microburst and that his whole
existence was brought into being through
Rick in an existential rage seep and
Rick begin beating the crap out of each
other
meanwhile Kyle crumbles into himself
with the realization that he's in a
nesting doll of universes and that's the
universe where I was born where my
father died where I couldn't make time
for his funeral because I was working on
my universe but Rick's triumph is
short-lived which brings us to step 6
paying a hefty price and suffering the
consequences given that this model is
circular you can imagine that there's
going to be a lot of symmetry going on
here
just as step two is about preparing the
hero for their descent step six is about
preparing them for their return this
step is all about the hero testing their
newfound will against the unfeeling
world often getting their asses handed
to them in the process Rick gets exactly
what he wanted a micro verse within
seeps Microverse but in demonstrating
Zeke's hypocrisy Rick causes Kyle to
have an existential meltdown and kill
himself trapping them all in the tiny
verse unable to put aside their egos
Rick and seat blame each other and set
out to destroy one another instead of
working together to escape the two set
up camps across from each other and
begin and all-out war completely
forgetting about their current
predicament
realizing that they're going nowhere
more decides he's better off living with
TreePeople but it's actually Morty and
his primitive tribe of tree people that
forces Rick and zeep to forge an
alliance which bring
us to step seven undoing the damage and
returning to the familiar world just as
step four is the final step before the
heroes sinks to the bottom of the
unfamiliar step seven is the final step
before they resurface the only problem
is that re-entering the old world is
just as difficult as leaving it once a
hero tries to return the denizens of the
deep are likely to give chase and
sometimes return with them using his
control over the tree people
Morty forces Rick and zeep to put aside
their egos and engineer a solution out
of Kyle's tiny verse but once they've
escaped it all bets are off and the two
groups rush to exit the surrounding
Microverse on a metaphorical level seep
is the embodiment of this lower world
he's there to stop Rick from bringing
the change back to the original world
getting his car battery running again on
a more literal level though Zeke wants
to trap Rick in the Microverse because
it's the only way to keep his own
Microverse from being destroyed in many
ways zeep is Rick's shadow serving is a
dark reflection of all Rick's
undesirable traits and neuroses shadows
are a common story device and like many
shadow figures before him zeep serves as
a gatekeeper for this lower world he's
the final obstacle a hero must face
whether it's hans gruber putting a gun
to John McClane's wife and die hard or
Luke facing off against Darth Vader in
Star Wars shadow characters offer a dark
glimpse into what the hero could have
been if they didn't undergo a
transformation the beauty of Rick and
Morty is that Rick is completely aware
of all his shortcomings and has no
desire to fix them the whole episode
presents us with a series of parallels
between Rick and seep making each look
as bad as the other when Rick tells
Morty to run it's hard to tell if he's
describing himself or zeep
as a result when reconceive finally face
off in the episodes conclusion it's not
rick battling the physical manifestation
of his demons in an attempt to change
it's just rick fighting rick even morty
feels the fight is unnecessary at this
point do it with zeep taken care of rick
and morty finally exit the Microverse
arriving back in their ball fondlers'
reality this brings us to step 8
change or the futility of it normally
this is where the hero finally reaches
fulfillment where he integrates all of
the skills he learned on his journey
into his old life in the Karate Kid
Daniel can now call the food in saw to
Amanda has become the next jigsaw killer
but remember TV isn't about change the
hero can never be fulfilled otherwise
they'll never desire another adventure
and there will be no story to tune into
once the two returned to their ball
fondlers' universe Rick turns the key
and the ignition starts he explains to a
confused Morty that zeep had either two
choices go back to Google box technology
or have Rick throw away a broken mike
reverse battery peace among worlds Rick
fully embracing the futility of change
the episode ends with the three sitting
down for ice cream a days Morty and
summers shell-shocked by the normality
of the situation after all they've been
through in the end rick and morty is
both immediately familiar and radically
different from anything we've seen on
television while the show regularly
mocks popular culture and continually
plays off the audience's expectations at
its core the series is structured just
like any other TV show but this is where
Rick and Morty shines the brightest
because while shows like happy days and
Leave It to Beaver are content to leave
us right where each episode started rick
and morty uses its circular structure to
make us confront the depressing
crippling futility of change rick
successfully Rhian slaves a whole planet
to power his car battery also they can
go get some ice cream
so while rick sanchez might not believe
in much the creative team definitely
believes in the power of story structure
and if you haven't seen our other Rick
and Morty videos click here or here to
check out our Rick and Morty playlist
where we have 5 other videos exploring
the philosophy of the show
this video is a bit of a change of pace
for us so if you liked it and would like
to see more let us know in the comments
thanks again for watching guys really
appreciate it
[Music]